hi steve kaufman here today i want to
talk about
difficulty
i think that learning a language is not
difficult
but i think that speaking another
language is difficult in other words
it's more difficult than speaking your
own language
okay
first of all on the difficulty of
learning a language it is not difficult
but it takes time
and i i
kind of the subject came up
because of a comment on our forum at
link
where we had a new member
i don't know if he's new but he's there
with his norwegian flag
and he says
my name is prepping eu norwege i'm
norwegian el vivo in brazil portrays mrs
milde i live hip hop he's iov i live in
brazil for three months in 2012 but now
aprendi nada i didn't learn anything
because i thought it would be difficult
to learn a language
brazil now his portuguese is not perfect
here i like brazil
aprender i want to learn and country
link okay he found link good for him and
immediately we have some brazilians who
come on here and say hola
preven seja benvindo a link
encouragement from the other members
what's this all about this norwegian
fellow lived in brazil for three months
in 2012
didn't learn portuguese because he
thought it was difficult it's not
difficult
we are
made to learn languages we learn our
native language we can learn other
languages
we learn them largely
in my opinion through exposure
so we gather these languages come into
our brain as we read as we listen it
sits there
the difficulty is
starting to speak
and because it is easier to speak our
own language it's more comfortable to
speak our own language so we have to be
motivated to speak another language
when i lived in montreal
as a child in the 50s english-speaking
people didn't learn french not because
it was more difficult in the 50s than it
is today today english-speaking people
in quebec learn french in the 1950s they
didn't it hasn't become easier to learn
french
what's what's changed is their attitude
the motivation
um when i watch my ukrainian television
some ukrainians many most ukrainians
speak both russian and ukrainian
uh
but there are
russian speakers there
and they don't necessarily have to be
you know
pro-russian
people in
east members of the government in kiev
some of them will always speak
in russian
even though they understand ukrainian
perfectly
because it's more comfortable for them
it's easier for them
if they wanted to speak ukrainian
they could do so but it means they're
going to stumble it means they're going
to get some words wrong they're going to
mix some russian with some ukrainian
it's going to be a little more difficult
to express themselves so
since everyone in ukraine understands
russian they just speak russian
uh so it does take a certain level of
motivation if you're a politician in
ukraine you have to learn to speak
ukrainian even if you're a russian
speaker
in canada if you're a politician you
have to learn to speak french even
though our prime minister doesn't do a
very good job of it he tries and reacts
also had francophone prime ministers who
spoke english and didn't do a very good
job of it either but they communicated
and i don't think that either the
present prime minister harper has any
complexes about his french even though
he's certainly not to be mistaken for a
native
and uh there was a fair amount of
criticism of
of
what was his first name dion there's
stefan dion and jacques
whose uh
english wasn't
you know neither one of those book
english
they both communicated
sufficiently well
the point in all this is
that learning a language in my opinion
is not difficult you just have to put in
the time and you can learn it passively
which is easier than trying to speak and
you can get used to the language acquire
your vocabulary but when it comes to
speaking to speak well you do have to
speak a lot and that is difficult only
in the sense that it is more difficult
than speaking your own language so you
have to be motivated enough to do
something which is not as easy
as
just speaking say english
and
so where's the motivation
i think the motivation can be
either because you need it or because i
find there's a sense of of achievement
of satisfaction it's almost this
make-believe world of at first that when
you start speaking another language and
you discover that bit by bit what you
say and you sound at first to yourself
you're not totally confident that what
you're saying makes sense and the other
person responds and seems to understand
what you're saying and i think all of
this gradual process of of getting
better and better at communicating even
though it's a slow process i think it's
it's motivating and it's motivating in
the sense that
it's a challenge that's that's difficult
but achievable it's not something that's
that's difficult and you're gonna fail
like my golf game is never going to
improve it's not like that it's it's
something where if you continue to put
in the time you will improve so
in summary then
learning a language is not difficult
speaking in that language is more
difficult than speaking in your own
language but it does have its
counterbalancing attractions that sense
of achievement that sense of
make-believe of being in a different
cultural environment
that sense of uh satisfaction when other
people understand you as you think
you're struggling to communicate
so um
and therefore you have to speak you have
to get over that obstacle and you have
to speak and you have to speak a lot
a lot and this is another problem i've
mentioned the difficulty that immigrants
have here where the government spends
hundreds of millions of dollars on esl
for immigrants most of whom don't do
very well because they're not
sufficiently motivated to actually you
know a spend the time with sufficient
content reading and listening to go home
and watch chinese videos
or b to go and talk to people
so
it's not inherently a difficult process
but you have to be motivated enough to
do it
and that's all so that's just some
thoughts on this issue of difficulty bye
for now